The general good experience,
so I went,
I went to like a day of media training
and it was a.
I did,
I did and it was the worst part was I've
done interviews and I've been fine
before,
but I got this guy sitting across from
me who's,
who's interviewing me doing this mock
interview and then I've got the
publicist and my writing partner and
they're just staring at me and that will
listen.
I can't do it.
Right.
All the pressures there.
Who's teaching you?
Who's teaching this training?
Here's where they right away.
Like,
you kind of suck at.
This.
Absolutely works.
I mean,
they were really nice about it.
They were like,
okay,
well there's some,
there's some room for improvement.
Oh my God.
Really?
Oh yeah.
No,
it was the worst.
It will seem like a natural.
I mean there's what is there to teach
you?
Well what?
Well this,
this is the thing that I'm really
comfortable with this,
with,
with us just hanging out here talking.
Sure.
But this is what I do is I yammer when
I'm nervous talker.
So you asked me a question if I'm
nervous.
I just kind of go and go and go and
people are like,
Geez
man,
that guy talk man.
So the thing is I got this guy sitting
across me,
really nice guy and he's The guy who's
coaching me,
but I know I'm going to give you like
fake interviews.
Well he probably quote you first.
He gave me.
He gave me a lot of really good insights
and the funny thing is every rule that
he's saying as he's saying it,
I'm going,
Oh yeah,
I do that.
like everything he's saying that I
shouldn't be doing.
I'm like,
oh yeah,
that's.
I always do.
What is he saying you shouldn't be
doing?
I mean that the main thing,
it's Kinda like what we were getting at
before that when somebody setting a trap
for you,
because so much of right now media
training is just about don't go out and
get yourself into trouble by going in
and just talking about some ridiculous
area that.
Because that's what people.
That's what everybody's trying to do
now.
Like just as a.
for example,
I did a Time magazine interview about
adoption about a year before we even
made the movie.
Really?
Yeah.
And it was just because I was in the
process of working on the movie and
anyway,
so the whole thing was just about
adoption and my family and whatever.
And it was right when the Harvey
Weinstein stuff was blowing up.
So ladies,
really nice interview.
And then at the end she says,
uh,
hey,
you know,
since I'm talking to a Hollywood
director,
I'd be remiss if I didn't ask did you
know about that Harvey Weinstein stuff?
And I was like,
Nah,
I didn't even think about my answer
because I don't know.
I didn't know the guy was never around
any of it.
That's sort of like more like fancy
movies.
And I was like,
yeah,
I know I don't.
I don't know.
I never met the guy,
whatever.
I didn't think anything of it.
I got off the phone and then I thought,
oh,
she didn't say,
what do you think about this stuff?
She said,
did you know about that stuff?
And it was like.
And I knew,
but I kept it a secret for those people
and I just thought right away,
you know,
the limiting factor was just like I was
just getting bored.
I wasn't actually breathing when we're
thinking of this is the thing.
I mean,
you had to,
at any given time,
any time you had to think of something
that was going to be more powerful than
the thought of stopping or fatigue or
clc get deeper into your skin.
And so sometimes it was really easy
because you were swimming with dolphins,
minky whales as one with the basking
shark.
Did they come over to you going,
what the fuck is this dude?
Yeah,
there was,
yeah,
there's a,
there was a video of that ages ago with
the,
uh,
the minky well,
and the,
I was filming 12 hours cross the Bristol
channel,
so that's kind of England to Wales.
And uh,
this was,
this was without doubt for all the
hardship that I've spoke about.
I just want to say there were some
amazing moments.
This one particular moment swimming
across the,
uh,
the Bristol Channel and all of a sudden
minky,
well,
kind of about big as this table breaches
right next to me.
And I was like,
whoa,
because I tend to map the captain.
I was like,
man,
am I safe?
Like,
what's going on?
Should I get out the door?
And he said,
no,
you're absolutely fine.
And I was like,
okay,
because he's a monkey wildlife that the
find the friendly.
I was like,
okay,
fair enough.
So I keep swimming and then for the next
five miles,
the minky whales circling me,
it was breaching over the top.
It was coming under me and swimming like
that.
I tend to mine.
I said like,
now what's going on?
And he said,
I've never seen this.
He's been sailing like 40 years.
He says,
I've never seen this.
He said,
but what I think is happening is I think
it's a female and I try to fuck you.
Well,
I said,
it's not mating season.
He was like,
no,
it's fine.
It's fine.
He goes,
what are these for later?
Have it here.
I mean,
I've seen him for four months in the
water.
I'm going to fuck mating seasons
probably right around the corner.
She was like,
if he sticks around to move on.
So
that was a concern of mine.
That was a good one.
Yeah.
And it was.
No.
Matt said,
no,
no.
I think it's a few more.
I think that she thinks that you're an
injured seal and so for the next five
miles she basically guided me all the
way to the shallower water and as I got
there,
it was literally the debt for the water.
Matt said,
Yep,
Yep.
Much shallower water.
And we turned whale breached one more
time and then.
And then swam off as if to say,
you know,
you're safe now.
Well why is there so much pushback
against this thing?
Is that I think what's going on as a
people worry that it doesn't look like a
problem to be solved anymore.
So when you.
When our kids,
we both have lots of gay friends,
but we didn't know it because they're
not telling anybody because someone's
going to kick their ass if they knew
that they were gay.
Gay people are still discriminated
against,
but it's so much better than it was.
Then.
What you don't want to.
What I think people are advocates don't
want to say is,
well,
there's no problem anymore because then
you can allow them to still run into
troubles in various circumstances.
Even though the trouble they run into
today is a thousand times less than the
trouble they ran two and little same
thing holds for racism.
Same thing holds for sexism.
They've all gotten so much better,
but and sexual violence is a perfect
example.
If you look at,
if you set,
this isn't pinker's book,
if you set rape and homicide to you call
it both of them,
whatever level they are in 1970 to 100
and then you track them through to the
early two thousands.
Homicide is in the U.
S homicides dropped to like 50 raves
dropped down to like 25,
but if you listen to women's advocacy
groups about campus sexual assault and
stuff,
you'd never know that and the reason you
wouldn't know it is because they.
People worry.
Well,
if you think the problem's getting
better on sound,
then you will keep doing anything to
help fix it.
And that's a really unfortunate part of
our psychology because it makes people
feel like there's been no progress and
when you feel like there's no progress,
then you think,
well maybe we need to completely
overturn the whole system and try
something new.
And that's of course the point of
pinker's newest book,
enlightened men now.
No things are going freaking great.
Turn it anarchy and all those things are
really bad ideas.
Voting for somebody like trump's a
really bad idea because things are
actually running along really nicely.
It's just that we tend to forget it
because every advocacy group who's all
worried about whatever their particular
issue is,
doesn't want the word to get out that
things are a lot better than they used
to be because I think at some
fundamental level they think,
well,
25 reps here isn't bad enough.
We better say that there's 100 or you
know,
I'm not saying they do this consciously,
but of course 25 reps here,
whatever the number is,
is bad enough.
Right.
It doesn't.
It doesn't have to be the numbers that
it used to be when I was a child to be a
problem at all.
It has to be as a number above zero
for my whole apprenticeship.
Alcohol was a reward.
You know,
you did a good job tonight.
Drink,
you know.
Then it went from a reward.
Do.
Oh Shit.
There was like a blood bath in the
restaurant.
You know,
we had to pick up this guy at the
hospital.
Okay.
It's not every word.
Let's forget about it.
Let's drink,
you know.
And it was,
it was always there.
You know,
it's great service.
Let's have a drink in the food industry,
but you're also in the wine industry
because 50 percent of what you're doing
is selling food to people and the other
50 percent of what you're doing is
selling alcohol at the people,
so by default you're part of the people
that sell a liquid drug dealer in that
you're in that world every day and you
go to wine tastings.
You'd talk with peoples that sell the
alcohol,
alcoholic bartenders.
You talked to people that sell wine,
you or partake in eating and other your
colleagues,
restaurants and drinking wine.
Next thing you know,
you have a little bit of celebrity.
You've been open for 15 years and you
look back and you go to seven days in a
week or seven days in a week and
I drank six of them.
I'll feel good on Sunday.
I'm just kind of recovering.
And then what?
What happens is one week turns into two
to four and then you kind of look back
and you realize in 2017 that you may
have drank 48 weeks out of 52,
you know,
and then it goes quick.
Then it's 10 years and your tenure
restaurant and you've been drinking five
days out of the week for 10 years and
then all of a sudden you kind of have a
problem.
You realize that like my day to day is
based on food and wine.
Right now.
I don't want my,
it's not making me happy.
I've had all the wines have had all the
foods.
My,
am I better for it?
Not really.
What am I better for?
Restriction eating less.
Eating clean.
Uh,
drinking only on very special occasions.
Do you still drink on special?
I don't want.
I'm completely sober.
No,
you see them and I've even seen them
switched teams and you see them switch
teams and I don't buy the
rationalizations when it comes to
ideology,
but I think is what they're doing is
they're switching teams because they
realize there's an end on this team and
they could just say this is the problem
with the team.
I used to be on those fucking losers and
they're,
they're really benedict arnold.
Right?
Like like they probably have as much of
an affinity to the ideas of one side is
a do the other side.
They just go all in on one side to get
acceptance from the group.
You just no way.
People change their opinion that much
over two years or something like that.
Or you know,
it's like they just decide this group
makes more sense now and I've been
attacked by people on the left so I'm
going to go to the right or vice verse.
And usually what it is,
is even when they say they've been
attacked,
like,
oh you fucking baby,
there's 300 million people just in this
country alone.
If you put something out there publicly
and a thousand people attack,
you don't act like you're being
persecuted.
Okay.
You have an idea.
You've,
you've,
you've launched that idea out into the
Zeit geist and people took a big shit on
it.
You know,
whether it's people on the right are
people on the left.
You've got to be able to argue your
point one way or the other and not just
immediately jumped ship when someone who
shares ideas with you decides that your
idea sucks and maybe they're wrong and
maybe you're right,
but you've got to argue that through,
but this idea of these partisan patterns
that people just seem to automatically
fall into.
There's so detrimental to dialogue
there,
so detrimental to us and really
understanding each other and really
having some sort of a sense of
community.
Right?
This is a giant community of 300 million
people.
That's what it's supposed to be and this
idea that it's this group is trying to
fuck it up and they're trying to turn us
all Muslims and this one wants everybody
to be gay and this one wants everybody
to have free food and this and this.
This is nonsense.
We need better understanding and,
and you know the word better.
Education gets tossed around a lot,
but it also means better social
understanding,
better social education,
like got an appreciation of who we are
and why we think the way we think and
calling out weasels on both sides of the
pattern,
like calling out weasels on the right
that are pandering,
that are just trying to like get the
repeating a lot of these like accepted
beliefs because they know that they can
hit this frequency and a lot of people
sing along or the same thing that other
people are doing on the left.
They're doing it on both sides.
I think most reasonable people have a
collection of ideas that they share from
both the right and the left and most
reasonable people are reasonably
compassionate and I think that's one of
the things that we're missing.
But uh,
yeah,
most places they have them and they're
managed and you go out and buy the small
game license for 12 bucks or whatever.
Get your hunter safety,
get yourself a 22 or a shotgun and you
can become a squirrel man or a squirrel
lady like your Buddy Kevin Murphy list.
One of my favorite guys on your podcast.
He's a squirrel man.
This guy blows a horn in the woods
before every hunt to alert the animals
that he's coming.
Yeah.
You blow up?
He carries a cow horn around.
I think the,
I think,
um,
it's in,
uh,
a show far.
Right.
Is that right for you when you blow the
Shofar and like a Jewish synagogue?
Is that what it is?
I think it's called a show far like
you've blown the rams.
They blow a Ram's horn.
It's not,
it's not a cow.
Yeah.
It's not a cow harm.
It's ran her near the end of,
um,
you know,
in the end have no country for old men.
Yeah.
Have we talked about this before?
He talks about his father riding out
ahead of him with a Horn of fire.
In the end when you get,
he relates the dream.
It's in the book and it's in the movie
for the Tommy Lee Jones characters
describing a dream in which they're
riding through a snowstorm and his
father rides ahead with a Horn of fire.
And I was wondering how many people
heard that and had no idea what he was
talking about,
but what a common practice used to be as
you take a horn buffalo horn,
cow horn,
and it's hollow because,
um,
it grows off of protrusion of the skull,
called the horn core.
Then you pop the horn off and it's
hollow.
And what people will do is when you left
your campfire in the morning,
you would fill that horn with embers and
cap it,
but there'd be a little pinhole in it
just to let a little bit of air and air
so could continue to smolder.
And you carry that Horn all day full of
embers.
And at night to start a new fire,
you would dump the horn out and rekindle
your fire.
So when he talks about his father riding
out ahead of them with a Horn of fire,
what that's meant to say is that he knew
his father will be waiting out ahead of
him with a fire burning.
Oh yeah.
But Kevin Murphy just blows it.
Let squirrels noise coming.